well we don't do things like we don't
believe in doing things like taking long
range pictures or buying pictures were
taking a long range of people sunning
topless in their backyards or on a yacht
we don't foot we don't photograph
children's schools like the children
celebrity their schools or reveal their
school addresses we don't reveal in fact
we don't reveal people's addresses
there's you know there's lines that I
feel have that we never have crossed
however that a lot of other media have
crossed at this point and it seems like
the same standards that that magazines
are held to or not the same in the
digital world and so some of the
websites I mean they've revealed all
kinds of things that we never would have
done
you